in reality there's no average when it
comes to abortions each person has their
own reasons circumstances life this
video is based in facts and statistics
to give a general look at who when and
why people have abortions the majority
of women receiving abortions are not
teenagers she's most likely a mother
with almost 60% of those seeking an
abortion already having given birth and
she most likely belongs to an organized
religion common reasons cited for
abortions include financial concerns and
the pregnancies interference with work
school and other responsibilities
according to 2005 research data from
2013 shows that a majority of abortions
happen in the first eight weeks of
pregnancy at that time the embryo is
approximately as large as a pencil
eraser and although very small and has a
beating heart by six weeks research from
the Royal College of Obstetricians and
Gynaecologists reported in 2010 that
before 24 weeks a fetus cannot feel pain
vacuum aspiration is the most common
method of in clinic abortions the
procedures performed by opening the
cervix wide enough to be able to use
suction to remove the pregnancy the
suction part lasts about one minute and
does not involve any incisions or cuts
it is not risk-free and there can be
bleeding and cramping afterward but
complications are rare and a 2014 study
conducted by the University of
California San Francisco minor
complications arose and less than 2% of
the abortions and major complications
happen very rarely there are more
complications at a higher risk of death
bringing a baby to term and giving birth
according to 2012 research after an
abortion it is normal to feel a range of
emotions but according to a study of
women who have had an abortion
the vast majority deemed at the right
decision and a study published in 2016
found that the risk of mental health
problems is no greater for women who
have had an abortion then for women who
have given birth after attempting to
obtain an abortion knowing these facts
will hopefully help change the way we
talk about abortions and the media with
our friends and family and with those
who have a different perspective
[Music]